All right,
here we go.
Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight but we wish we
were brought to you by wd 40 cause Brian I think I shit is constantly squeak in.
So when we would be like here,
all that,
it's really the springs,
the springs of the problem.
But I wonder if like just a little splash of wd 40 wouldn't save the day.
Joe.
Maybe it would,
maybe it wouldn't.
Maybe it would just smell a garage in here then.
Oh God,
that'd be high blood guys need a free case of that.
I free case wd foot out and then maybe a little bit of sponsorship.
Think the reality of the uncensored nature of this podcast makes it very
problematic for anybody to want to be professionally associated with it.
I don't know if I go in my dad's garage,
he has a fucking Pamela Anderson poster on the wall and he has all these wd 40
products.
They have like these deputy 40 pens now where it's just like if you just want to
dab something with the fleshlight wd 40 is a lubricant.
You imagine.
Imagine what kind of damage your duty a dick.
If you fuck the flush lines,
wd 40 does that shit all day.
What do you think that's square black spot in his hair is,
it's from to juicing all over his fucking head.
Wd 40 squirting out the tip of the functioning of those got black loads.
Oil like loads.
It's been around cars too long to imagine if you love cars so much that you
really tried to jerk off to gasoline.
You really try to pour gas in your hand and beat off with it.
I mean it is like a lubricant,
right?
Liquid could.
You have to be unbelievably painful,
right?
You realize you're,
you're pitching some sort of extreme reality show.
Like what can you check off with?
Yeah,
and it's a combination of some perverted show and like name that tune.
I can jerk off with gasoline.
Joe Rogan chuck off with that gasoline.
No,
I can,
I can get to fuck a bandanna on because the fumes come in.
Three strokes.
Yeah.
How many aces that didn't take,
how many,
how many minutes?
How many minutes?
If you had a race to come ready,
go,
there's a fucking camera on you.
You're alone in a fucking white room and you,
you don't get to watch it.
What else peed off?
So you have to imagine,
and it's for $1 million,
the people who get off on that up,
people who always fantasized about being in a room with just a cat.
Yeah.
If you were shows always turned me on.
I don't know what it was.
If you are a freak reality star gay dude,
that would probably be a good gig for you.
You could probably like win that contest the quickest outright.
Yeah.
Cause you know you would really be worried about guys watching you beat off.
Or like athletes who don't freeze up and like game seven,
I can take the big shot.
They don't care if like with all that attention,
I was watching some documentary on prison and there was one dude who claimed
that he had an affair with a,
there was a female prison guard and he wound up,
I'll fucking this female prison guard and some,
some shit went on.
She got in trouble for it.
Wow.
The Guy,
apparently
he could make his dick hard and ejaculate all without touching himself.
That's how much free time that dude had.
That dude was in jail for so long.
They figured out.
Talk about game though.
Yeah,
to be in the prison cell.
You know she's fucking with their career.
Her ability to mortgage still got it.
He probably did that trick he got,
he showed her that.
I think he showed her that.
I bet she just couldn't take it.
I mean that is like the ultimate pimp move.
You're in a cage locked up in a cage and you can make yourself not all of
yourself and it's so hot that the guard,
the one person who's,
she's free,
she just works there.
She just works around you and you're stuck in up.
What did he do for a crime?
I don't know.
I wish I had all the details of the story or the not.
It was actually true,
you know?
I mean she could have just made that shit up,
but that's a pretty extraordinary thing.
Is there a guy who can do that?
I've seen guys blow themselves.
I didn't know if it was I with the guy who,
uh,
we went to,
we went to a titty bar and a d,
I don't think he got a lap dance.
He was just looking at this girl.
He got so turned on,
he blew it in his pants and I w I laughed.
He didn't tell me until like weeks later.
And it was one of the hardest I've ever laughed because he was laughing.
He had a great sense of humor about himself,
so I'll do it if it was just one of those fucking,
you just crying,
laughing like there was the first wave of what do with this fucking way.
And he was like,
dude,
I don't know how I was just sitting there.
He's like a pothead.
I just sit and I don't know,
I just came this pants.
Anyway,
this is the longest fleshlight commercial.
That's like some shit.
Maybe you do it when you like,
I dunno.
11 o'clock the commercial reminder.
12 yeah,
that's ridiculous.
The ability.
We've got bill Burke contact high.
I think
bill,
Bro,
you might be contact high right now,
son.
You might've got hot box in the small room and it could have happened.
Go to Joe Rogan,
not net,
click on the link for the flashlight and then the code name,
Rogan and you will save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
We were also brought to you by on it on it,
makers of Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech immune and a new mood.
The five HTP and serotonin boosting supplement.
All that stuff is answered on on it.com if you have any questions,
rather it's all answered on on at.com it's a w what they are is essentially
their nutrients that make your brain function better.
It's very controversial,
I believe in it and I wanted make it as easy as possible where people don't feel
even remotely ripped off and because of that,
the way we have it set up the first order 30 pills you by you,
you can,
you get a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the pills.
You just say this stuff doesn't work.
You get 100% of your money back.
We're way more concerned with making sure that nobody feels ripped off than we
are with making money.
That's,
that is my number one priority
and all of these things,
all these different nootropics are all things that I've been into before I ever
had anything to do with it.
If you use the code name Rogan,
you'll save yourself 10% off.
Okay.
Cue The magic pill bars here.
And like I said,
I think
we got a contact Rogan experience try by day Joe Rogan podcast.
Is that a new thing you're doing?
They're Dj's
Dj r d
powerful bill burr.
Good to see you buddy.
What's going on?
Good to see you too,
sir.
Fucking awesome to have you come down here again.
Always.
Always a good time.
And you were telling a fucking hilarious story about eating a pot Brownie and
about how fucked up it.
Got Ya.
Yeah.
I'm guessing this is the story that you had told on our first podcast,
but I forgot it,
but it's fucking hilarious.
It's true.
Kids don't,
don't just John just eat pot.
That shit is way stronger than smoking pot four to five times more psychoactive.
Yeah.
Nobody told me that the person didn't know and uh,
yeah,
so I had two and a half.
I have a sweet tooth.
You know what I know.
No,
I had one,
she had half of one right.
She had half of one.
Then I ate her other half,
I don't remember.
And then there was another half left and I threw that you cause cause she was
getting high and I wasn't feeling anything.
And then we got in a car and went to Newark Airport to go fly a Costa Rica.
And by the time I got there,
dude,
it was,
it was insane.
I was like borderline
hallucinating dude.
The,
the eating of it is like if you go back to like early literature on Hash eating,
like what would the kinds of things that people were describing when they were
eating hash,
incredible psychedelic experiences.
People don't realize that's not just like getting hot.
You're not just like smoking a little reefer and kicking back and hey this
movie's kind of Vani is fucking pizza tastes so good now.
Now you ate two pot brownies and where you probably should have ate a quarter of
one of them cause they're fucking notoriously strong.
Nobody ever,
when was the last time you ever heard of anybody getting a like really shitty
brownies?
Seven days ago,
seven days ago.
You heard PR,
somebody getting Shitty Brown.
I got shitty Brown.
Yeah,
I think there were mushroom brownies.
Oh,
you just got them from a dude.
Some guy just gave it to me how to fucking show and then I felt like I was
tripping.
Crazy.
You're eating things.
People just giving you a chance.
That's like Jim Morrison Shit fucking down the street eating whatever anybody
gives you the dispatch.
I go to a dispensary that I trust and there you get used to whatever they're,
they're sort of labeling is,
you know.
But when you got to ask them like what?
Like what do you do?
[inaudible] I know like,
like governmental sticker that's on there like this is,
you know,
4.5%.
Well then alcohol,
it gets silly because they have like axes,
especially baked goods.
See the with marijuana,
if it's just the marijuana that you,
it's pretty obvious,
you know,
it's all,
even if it's really strong marijuana,
it's still,
you know what you're smoking,
you know what the size of it is.
You know how much THC is going to get in there from a bowl or a joint.
When you eat something,
they have these weird labels on,
I'm like five x and three x,
but x is,
there's no real x.
It's not like x equals 10 milligrams.
It's just they're just making it up.
So it doesn't mean anything.
This smelling when you guys smoked,
it took me back to that fucking hurt.
I'll set up.
It'd be like if you ever puked on a grant,
you know what I mean?
Like I long time ago I,
one of the worst side of acute was drinking rum and cokes and for like 25 years,
I never,
I never had another run,
not 25 what am I talking about?
That old like 20 years.
It just smelled it and it would just immediately associated with peaking
outside,
you know,
underage drinking and the type of shit.
So when I smelled that stuff,
I was just like,
oof.
I had one of those Jack Daniels for a long time to fucking that.
The first time I got drunk,
I got drunk with some friends in high school and Oh my God,
I didn't had no idea what I was doing.
I mean there's just no
Jack Daniels.
Yeah.
At a party with a bunch of my friends that were all too,
we're all like serious stoners,
but I wouldn't smoke pot because I was too in martial arts and I thought that
part was a drug and pot would fuck you up,
but I would drink every now and then with them and the first time I ever did it
was,
oh my God,
I was so crazy.
Gusting Lee blasted untracked Daniels.
I was the old Milwaukee just in comparison
grows couple of scrolls and I drank like a third.
I'm like,
am I drunk?
You know,
there's no way.
Or we do jack too year,
we're car.
I threw up in a taxi,
a taxi cab threw up in the backseat of the cab.
It's fucking horrible.
I can barely remember it when I'm,
when I talk about something that happened when I was like 14 or whatever the
hell I was,
it doesn't seem like I'm telling the truth.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it seems like a kind of have a memory of that.
But boy is it fucking fuzzy.
You know?
If I had to describe to you like moments in high school because it was so long
ago,
a long fucking time ago,
man,
I'm 44 now.
When I look back when I was 14,
I don't really remember what the fuck happened back then.
I remember a few things I can tell you where we lived to tell you my street we
lived on,
but if I try to get specific with,
I went back to where I grew up the other day and um,
it was,
uh,
it was really fascinating.
Man.
Went back to the house and the w w when I went to high school,
that,
that era of my life and everything looked different than I imagined it.
It was,
it was very strange.
It was like,
man,
my memories of this shit or blurry,
it's fuck.
Like you can start pulling them.
When you go back to towns then like you go,
oh yeah,
remember this is where we did this.
Oh yeah,
this is what we do that and he'd,
they'll,
they'll start pulling back.
Cause you go in,
it been since you went back home.
Oh it had been a long fucking time.
I moved out of Boston and probably 90 91 maybe 92 so you haven't been back in
like 21 years had been,
I had been back just every now and then to do gigs.
Like Boston itself made sense to me.
But then I went to Newton where I grew up and I went like the house where I used
to live.
I went and looked at that and I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
This is strange.
She's done that.
Going back to houses when I was a kid you thought the front yard was like nine
miles so he can make it to the front door in two steps.
That's why when you were a kid you thought it snowed more.
It's because you are a midget.
You're literally walking around.
Every snow storm was up to your waist,
you know?
I think that's good for you.
I think it's good to grow up in a place where it snows to have a little respect
for nature.
You know?
Versiti we grew up in Boston,
men in Boston,
you fucking respected nature for six months out of the year for six months out
of the year.
You knew what the fuck was going on.
If you had a flat on the side of the road,
you might die.
Okay,
how about that?
How about that?
And now you can be out on your way to Mansfield and they don't.
They don't find you in time.
The state patrol,
you know?
But the goal is by some guy driving by that happened to a friend of mine from
high school dead.
He was changing a tire.
Can I hit the car and killed him?
Oh yeah.
Fuck that man.
It bring up a bad memory.
I remember going,
being convicted of drinking and driving.
I had to go to a mothers against drunk driving meeting and I was all paranoid is
going to be like 10 mother's screaming at me.
But what a piece of shit I was.
And when I went there,
it was the exact opposite.
It was like 200 drunk sitting there and some woman trying to tell the story
about her kid while all these fucking drunks bitched about their cases tour
going like,
oh,
he blew a 0.08.
And she standing up,
they go,
well,
you know,
you probably should discuss that with the,
uh,
with the judge.
So Johnny was changing his tire after practice.
It was fucking,
no,
that was a watershed moment for me because I couldn't judge him.
I was like,
I am in this demographic of fucking idiots.
It's like I am a 22 year old freshman in college.
I'm a fucking loser.
And like within 12 months I,
uh,
started doing standup and I got away from all of that crap.
But uh,
you don't drink at all anymore right now?
I do.
I took a year,
a year and two days off.
I wish I didn't start back up.
It's just a bad habit.
I mean,
I don't get like,
you know,
but,
uh,
I love it.
I love drinking.
I love getting hammered.
I hate,
I hate the next day how I feel.
Yeah.
But uh,
I like all that shit.
I like,
oh,
I mean all this shit that's bad for you.
I like it.
Yeah.
It's a very unfortunate that next day feeling no,
you got to switch the waters at some point.
That's when you become a professional.
But like,
that still doesn't really have when really all I got one buddy of ranking
yourself.
Yeah,
no,
I understand.
I mean,
none of it.
I do bad shows if I'm hung over,
I don't like my shows.
They don't feel good.
They don't have the flow to them,
you know?
And I,
I just,
I hate that feeling.
I hate the feeling of being on stage and it's,
it would be my fault if I was hung over.
I was hung over on seats.
It's like,
it's my fault that I'm working at like three quarter right now or it's not
clicking right now.
Like,
that's so cool.
I wish I could just have one,
but it's not satisfying because you have one and then you want a hundred and
then,
and then you drink a hundred and then you feel like shit.
And like if I just drink one,
like I've have one at lunch,
then it's like I want to go take a nap.
Right?
Yeah.
I either got to keep going.
If I keep going,
I can go for like,
you know,
a good hardcore for or a gentleman six
and then I'm done.
But like,
uh,
I,
yeah,
I feel pulled to it.
No.
Is it like Gollum in the ring?
No,
I just,
I don't know what that means.
I just like,
no,
no.
I like,
I don't even know what that is.
I don't want to see the Lord of the rings.
You didn't see that the Lord of the rings.
I went to one of those and it was so fucking long and every time they would,
they would fade to black.
I'd be like,
just roll the credits,
roll the credits,
and then they would open up on some big field and it's just like Jesus,
get the fucking thing back to the guy so we can get out of here.
I hate,
I,
you know what,
I fucking hate all of it.
And I fucking paid people who don't have a sense of humor about the bullshit
that they watched when they were kids.
Like adults who talk about star wars,
like that isn't a fucking movie now when you watch it,
I mean like how busy,
terrible.
I was making fun the other night.
The other night I came home,
I got,
I got free,
uh,
free Cinemax,
which is the greatest fucking channel ever.
They either w 24 hours a day.
They're either showing the greatest movie ever or the worst fucking movie ever.
And it's all compelling as I watch like nine movies in a row,
like this fucking channels.
Unbelievable.
So I ended up flipping up,
uh,
cause late at night.
They just had some sort of,
you know,
softcore porn,
which is ridiculous now when you have the Internet.
So just was redundant.
Sorry,
I got off of that.
So I went on to VH one.
Uh,
and,
and they were playing this to show metal mania and I was watching all these
bands and these videos that I just thought were fucking sick and they were
injured.
The devil dude,
I was just by the NFL.
It's like,
how was this better than disco?
Like why did disco gets so much shit?
Like I'm not talking about like the iron maidens,
the metallic,
but you know what I'm talking about?
That middle of the fucking ground,
those people with the spiked fucking gloves and all this stupid shit and raw
meat and it was just,
it was horse shit.
It was fucking,
I watched it.
It was the dumbest shit ever.
It was embarrassing that I,
I mean I moved,
granted I had all of that music still on my iPod.
I am not,
I'm not above it.
But if someone were,
were from this generation where to come back and tell me that music was awful
and it was stupid,
I would laugh.
There's like,
there's no way I could defend it.
Isn't it weird how you look at,
like if you look at music or you look at movies,
that's like one of the clearest examples of like some sort of a evolution or
progress is going on with humans because like the,
the movies
of the past,
like so many of them are there are so clunky.
N the,
the,
the style of communicating is so artificial.
It looks,
it's,
it's such a shit,
you know,
representation of life in comparison to a real good mood until the 60.
Once they figure it out,
you know,
like just acting on film,
like those people just learning how to do it.
So everything was,
was gonna be not wanting to talk to Tom Ferry.
Yeah.
That type of acting had to go away with the Brando's and the James Deans and
those guys.
And then you had to have like the,
uh,
there's a couple of,
with like,
there's movies back there like Jack Lemmon,
the apartment.
Well,
the hustler is way ahead of his time that the hustler movie.
Stanley Kubrick.
Yeah,
that type of shit.
There were some delays.
It still holds up though.
But those were the bad movies from the 60s and the 70s you know,
watch like try to wash like Jaws Three d oh yeah,
no,
that's good.
That's bad.
That's a bad one.
This was this a bad,
they've always had,
they still have movies like sure.
I mean,
I think along the shore to this day,
that transformer shit,
even though I didn't see it,
but if you see and I never got,
I never vibed with Scifi people,
like Scifi listeners,
I always get trashed by them because I just don't,
I just don't get it.
Unless you don't get Psi Phi at all.
No.
If it's like aliens,
like it has to be high quality like aliens.
It's like the Goodfellas of that side.
I like on like top shelf Scifi.
I'm going to be in the blade runner,
the aliens and that type of Shit,
but if I'm just going to go watch,
you know,
oh we're,
we're in hoth.
I didn't,
what the fuck that's from?
What is hoth?
Is that,
that's a star wars thing.
I don't know.
I don't know what that is.
Like one of those fucking things.
The action figures and shit.
It's just,
did you like transformers?
I didn't like,
I didn't like to Baka Baka Baka it's like,
dude,
you're a fucking fucking awesome guy to have around.
He's huge.
Yeah.
Imagine you can party with big foot.
I would totally party should be ripping somebody his arms off.
He's shooting a gun.
Like he's a fuck.
He's like,
he's,
he's a bad ass limit is how to shoot guns too.
He'll rip the fucking arms off,
but he can also shoot you from a distance.
Bitch.
She's limited.
Oh,
I liked you bought star wars.
I would totally hang out with,
no,
I didn't like about him.
He was a follower.
Well started.
He started hanging out with all the humans and next thing he knows he's sitting
up right.
And shares.
Right,
right.
SIP it.
A little juicy juices.
Yeah.
I wonder if he can understand.
He could,
they understand him.
They could speak that.
I think it was a language,
but we just didn't understand it.
So all that same fucking thing every time.
Not that many rookies.
You know,
it's like Chewbacca and like there's no other famous what?
He was like the Dodo bird.
Oh isn't that weird?
We're going to be destroyed on Twitter cause we are star wars knowledge suck
and
there's a fucking million WorkKeys.
There is a nation of Lucky's.
There is a federation of low keys.
You know,
not what you're talking about.
There's nothing better than just having a fucking 10% knowledge of those rooms
criticizing them because it's just driving kid nuts.
If you look at old TV shows like father knows best and then watch.
What's something good today?
Well the office or in is the office code.
That's what you're supposed to say.
Watched it.
I think it's good.
I haven't,
I haven't watched a sitcom in years.
I haven't watched anything since.
Maybe Larry Sanders.
I just watched sports.
Larry Sanders,
unless something huge happens.
His name Larry David.
Jesus clarity.
I was watching some classic Seinfeld last night.
That shit is fucking hell by the way.
That was an awesome show.
Larry Sanders.
I don't know why I pulled that out of my ass.
Yeah,
but yeah.
it was amazing.
Show Seinfeld,
remember that?
That episode where Elaine,
every time she went to the doctor,
that doctor wrote down notes about her and then I only saw a few Seinfeld's
quite honestly,
maybe solid five or six of them ever for whatever reason.
Cause you were headlining and you were on a hit sitcom that was not on a hit
sitcom.
I was on a sitcom that was like number 84 and the ratings when news radio was
on,
it did terrible.
It was terrible in the ratings.
Great.
Did good when it was in good time slots.
But they moved us around nine times over five years.
So there was nobody ever got cocky,
have you put I was like,
yeah,
fuck.
It was always that.
There was always that good show that they just kept moving around and like the
creators were like losing their fucking minds.
But you guys made syndication though,
right?
I yeah,
I did,
but barely.
It's Kinda funny.
We only did 98 episodes.
You're supposed to have a hundred for syndication.
I'm pretty sure we only had 98 but how does that work?
Do you get checks now for like 3 cents?
Does it still work?
Like it was a halfway decent?
No,
that's okay.
The people,
people think you get really rich from it.
The people that get rich from it are the people that own it.
So if they say if you all in the show and you sell it,
but like the actors there,
they're going to get compensated.
They get compensated very well.
But it's not like a,
but a show runner make.
So when people see like oh he's on syndication,
he's rich.
No,
not necessarily at all.
Cause it seems like the stuff I do the first time you get paid,
it's great.
Next time they cut it in half on the second running and then all of a sudden
then you start getting checks for a dollar 30 but when you Tim Allen or someone
like that who has a home improvement,
then you know he owns,
I'm sure he must have owned a chunk of that show.
So when that shit goes to syndication you just fuck it,
rake it in.
It was worth it for him,
I guess to stop doing standup for a long time.
I know I shouldn't speak out of turn because I don't know if this is really
true.
This is just what I had heard was that Tim Allen,
who was a very good stand up,
you ever watched him?
Alan back in the day.
That's what I heard was a very good stand up and a,
you know,
a fun guy to watch.
He was fun and,
but he's,
his show was like just a little rowdy,
you know,
just not,
not dirty.
Not really.
You know,
it wasn't like a Kennison or anything like that,
but I guess,
uh,
it was too,
too rowdy for the show.
And they were saying,
you know,
look,
you're going to be on home improvement.
You know,
you should turn that shit down and you should,
you should stop performing.
Right.
You're out there and you,
you know,
you're saying crazy things about drills and hammers
and you know,
you're going to get us in trouble.
So it's probably wasn't the shit about the drills and hammers.
I imagined it was a shit about jail.
Fucking Michigan or whatever.
That's all it was.
Coke.
Yeah.
That I would want,
I would want to hear.
Yeah,
well that was a weird thing when I,
when you hear about that,
they like,
well you could,
you go to jail and then wind up on TV.
That's pretty fucking bad ass.
No.
When you get out of jail is to,
you get into sales or show business.
Those are the only two places they don't give a fuck.
I had to guy up,
well,
you know,
do like five bring up the next year.
It was a dude that we knew from Rhode Island that Peter got at death with a
stick.
I'm just thinking about this car right now.
Do you,
did you know Eddie Galvin?
Okay.
Uh,
no.
From Rhode Island.
What was he gone by the time you were,
uh,
you were coming around Galvin?
Yeah.
I would remember the guy if he get beat to death.
No,
no,
no.
He didn't get beat to death.
He beat the guy to death.
Oh,
heckler.
I'm sure I'm saying his name right.
Okay.
Who was a really funny guy though.
He was one of those Brian Holtzman type guys.
There was just like,
comics would be like,
get into the back of the room to watch him when he would go on stage and just
go,
Jesus fucking Christ.
And he just say that he was a crazy dude.
Who did he beat to death?
Some guy.
The story.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what happened.
I might not even be right.
Jesus.
What did,
what did you smoke before this random?
No,
I'm just saying it doesn't even know if that happened.
You just started a Rhode Island in this whole movie started playing in your
head.
What's a fighting people beating people to death.
What's a famous movie that was shot in Rhode Island with some,
it gets beat to death.
I bet that's just playing in his head.
Right.
That's what he's remembering.
You ever see a friends of Eddie Coyle?
Is that as I saw that,
that the um,
uh,
Mitchum movie.
Robert Mitchum.
Yeah.
What a fucking great movie that was a guy.
What's his face from everybody loves Raymond is in it,
right?
Yes.
Peter.
Uh,
Peter Boyle.
Yeah.
Put Your Peter Boyle.
I just saw that in the past year.
All of a sudden like resurfaced.
Peter Boyle was a fucking amazing actor.
Holy Shit was that guy could,
that's a great movie.
That is a really good movie.
I like those kinds of movies.
That's the kind of shit I still like if I buy something on DVD,
I'm going to buy like the dirty dozen.
Yeah.
Magnificent seven like that era.
You know what I bought the other day Lamont's with Steve McQueen.
Yeah.
God Damn.
That's how you used to come out once a year.
They would play that on either TV 38 or Wl VI channel 56 I was saying this shit
cause I know you grew up that area and I up.
That's why I watched all those guys,
all that Bronson Lean,
Marvin,
uh,
Clint Eastwood,
all of that Shit.
And it was on a rotation the same time every year that they would play like the
eight o'clock movie.
Steve McQueen.
Did you ever watch it?
You've seen the Mons?
Yeah.
There was like parts in that movie for like,
Oh like five,
10 minutes.
We're,
no one said a word.
Yeah.
For like 10 minutes.
Like you watched the movie,
they're changing,
tires are setting things up.
People go and get a cup of coffee.
All this shit is chicken place.
No one's talking at all.
They're like wow,
this is like a era.
It's a different world.
Yeah.
That's when the directors took over the world of like Stanley Kubrick,
you know the world of 2001 a space before that whole movement happened that back
in the day,
like at the director,
all the director did for the most part was just make sure that you were in frame
that you said everything you said.
And in the second you wrapped on the movie,
the studio took it and they edited the thing.
Wow.
And it wasn't until,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm really speaking out attorney cause I don't,
I know about as much about this as I do about star wars.
But like somewhere in the 60s is when the director started taking over going
like,
no,
this is my fucking film.
I'm going to edit this and we want to do it this way.
That was sort of the first wave of that.
And when that happened,
that's when you had all the uh,
dust on apocalypse now.
Yeah.
Oh,
that was sort of the,
the,
that the lady that was 10 years after.
But that kind of,
that kind of movie,
that's where that comes from.
And that,
that was like,
that during that time,
like art was ridiculous.
The music,
you have the tail end of the Beatles going on,
those directors we've taken over and then,
you know,
Richard Pryor was like finding his voice and like stand up was coming out to the
forefront.
Like that whole error in uh,
in artists is incredible,
but it's funny.
But then they just,
you know,
that 70 show,
they just boil it down to like lava lamps.
It was a little more interesting shit going on back then.
And I,
I mean,
I know,
I know it's just a sitcom,
but I'm just saying,
you know,
they do the early seventies is Nixon resigning and the late seventies is
everybody doing coke,
listening to disco and then like,
well that's that decade now we're into the 80s.
How about Michael J j Fox picture.
I remember when Nixon was president.
Do you remember?
And then when I was a kid,
listen to him crying on the radio when he stepped down first Kent State and then
Watergate.
Like has there ever been a more fucked up crooked guy shooting at fucking
college students?
Is that Johnson was an opposite.
Oh no,
that was the extent.
Those next,
well he wasn't there with the rifles was,
he probably was.
It was probably his idea was son of a bitch.
He probably wanted us to silence these fucking punk kids.
Nixon was a creepy dude,
man.
He was the fact that you were,
you're so paranoid that you fucking record yourself having conversations.
Like what?
What you thought was going to happen to you?
I think losing to Jack Kennedy just fucked with his head.
Yeah.
Cause I guess he blew him away in the debates on the radio.
But if you watched it on TV,
Jack was sitting there looking like a movie star,
looking like fucking Tony Curtis.
He's sitting there looking like some guy waiting to get his teeth cleaned.
It is true.
People will vote for looks.
No.
He went from almost winning the presidency to his entire career being fucking
over.
He then lost I think the governor race or something like that in California and
he was completely out of office and they were like,
that's it.
Game set,
match and like within four years,
I don't know what happened.
He signed a deal with the devil.
That guy was an in office.
What?
Lyndon Johnson was growing
his hair going crazy and Nixon slid in.
Bobby Kennedy got whacked.
There's a kill you that they just fucking knocked down the ambassador hotel.
Like they just don't give a fuck about history out here.
I was in Dallas.
They would have like an entire like w like the entire
block would be preserved.
Do you think it's an embarrassment?
You think that's what they knocked it down because that's what Kennedy was shot?
No,
cause they think they do with everything.
I find it frustrating out here because a I,
it's,
it's very hard to feel grounded out here with just the end.
Endless like strip malls.
If there's like a piece of history,
there's a way to be like,
okay,
this is from then and this is what happened and then this happened and now we're
here.
This is the steakhouse where John Gadi shot Paul Castillo.
Yeah.
Shit.
Like in New York,
the triangle shirtwaist fire and they got a little plaque,
they got all that shit.
You can kind of be like right.
There's a bunch of native Americans buried under here.
The Astors got a bunch of blood money and now they have a subway stop named
after him Cooper Union,
that type of shit.
But you,
you're out here and it's just like a,
you know like they had like you know before nine 11 like the big,
the biggest like act of terrorism,
like you know,
blown up a building,
people jumping to their death and shit was the first La Times building and it's
not the one that's there.
If somebody blew it up at like two in the morning at the turn of the century and
there's not,
I can't find it on the fucking Internet where it was,
I don't know what's there.
There's no plaque,
there is no nothing.
Go Fuck you.
Self burn down his the new one.
Wow.
And that's it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
There's not much of a sense of history here.
I mean there's like the Chinese theater,
right?
That's the big thing.
Mann's Chinese theater.
That's like a lounge,
that ambassador hotel.
I guarantee you there's like a burger king sitting on top of it.
They don't give you a staples.
It's just,
I dunno,
that's the one thing out here that I,
I uh,
that fucks
me.
After a while we filmed fear factor there.
We filmed an episode there.
I remember being weirded out.
You went to it and I never went.
I walked through the kitchen.
I walked through where he got shot and what was going on at that time was it,
was it shut down?
Well,
it's a,
they rented out to,
for filming the rented out to people make movies there and they were there were
making TV shows.
How,
how,
how creepy was that?
I would have loved it.
It was bizarre.
I wish I had known.
I wish.
I don't think I knew you then.
But if I had known or you weren't here,
then I think I was living in New York.
I had met you,
but if you,
if I,
yeah,
if I knew someone was like a crazy Kennedy freak,
that's a no,
no.
Just a history,
like that type of stuff.
But I mean that,
that,
but that's the,
I'm like,
come on,
man.
That's like,
did you ever go through that place in Dallas too?
Have you ever driven through Dealey Plaza?
Weird,
right?
Yeah.
No,
it was that,
that was too much.
They preserve the,
you feel like it's weird that you're not in black
as you're walking around.
I mean,
they literally,
if you've never been there to your listeners,
the entire block is this just watch,
was it this of the film?
Yeah.
That's the one in color.
You're going to,
you're going to see,
you're going to,
you're going to see those buildings.
I mean at the same color.
The whole thing.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a real mind fuck to cause a block away.
It's 2012 and you go there and it's November,
1963 bill hicks had a great fucking choke about that place.
He goes,
uh,
you go to the up to the book depository and he goes and I try to do a Bill Hicks
accident.
And he goes,
uh,
and they have it marked off and it looks exactly the way it did in 1960.
What was it?
Three you got shot?
He 1963 no.
Why?
Cause Oswald's not in there
as well as not there either.
That's hilarious.
He goes,
they don't let you look out the window as he walks in.
Oh,
so I'm the patsy.
That's the one that always sends a chill baby.
You don't do it.
I think everything is bullshit.
I think the is fixed.
That's what we are.
Most things.
So most obvious pieces of bullshit.
And you know what site?
Some fucking sports are fixed,
man.
That's reality now.
It's a lot of money.
Eight the NBA had a mop.
Yup.
Ref.
And then they did an inhouse investigation and then they did the Oswald acted
alone.
Nothing to see here.
And they found,
how'd they catch the guy?
Um,
how did they get to that a Ferrari?
You know what?
I don't even know.
I just get the number
came on the news and you know,
all gamblers were all yelling.
I fucking know it.
I know it.
I knew this shit was fixed and um,
then they tried to say it was just him and I,
you know,
I'm not saying they all are,
I'm just saying like,
look,
I always compare it to this like,
like,
dude,
remember when you had a day job and shit,
if two people were hooking up on the Diallo,
how long did it take you to figure they thought nobody knew.
You could tell by their body language.
You could tell what the fuck they were doing.
You can't tell me you on an NBA officiating team and you can't tell somebody is
fixing games.
How many times?
Okay,
it was kind of weird tonight.
Then he's weird again and then weird again.
All of a sudden you've gotta be like,
this guy is a,
I don't know if you're sitting in the crowd and you could notice.
I just don't think another professional referee can't notice.
I think it's they're investigating it right now.
I heard one guy.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
no,
we already went to jail.
He's already in jail.
Oh,
they already talking about the pack fight in your mind.
Oh No,
no,
no.
We weren't talking about that,
but we've gone to,
I was going to ask you,
what do you think about Pacquiao Bradley was that fixed?
That was the worst decision I've ever seen in the history of boxing.
Never seen such a bad decision.
I didn't watch it,
but here's my,
my,
I don't know shit about the fight game,
believe it or not to look at me.
I don't know anything about it,
but I find it amazing that someone could come in at his light of weight,
put on 40 pounds,
not lose any speed,
be actually be stronger.
Like I don't know how,
how do you do that?
I don't know Ma.
Okay.
No Man.
You got to talk to him about all,
I would never,
never that guy he did,
he'd had button me than sing me a song and then wait for me to wake up and kick
the shit out.
I'm again.
Right.
What do you need explosives?
Looking for my phone.
Oh,
did you leave it in the bathroom?
No,
that was what,
that's what I was worried about it.
I'm sorry.
I panicked
I think.
I think uh,
yeah,
I think the NBA is just as filthy as boxing.
Do you?
What did you,
did you watch the boxing match?
Did you see the packout Bradley fine?
No I didn't,
but I've watched boxing.
I see what happens.
The only fight where I've never,
I've never heard of a fight before where I haven't met a single person that
thought Bradley one,
not one person.
I mean they must be out.
So what's the reason for doing it?
Took to just make a bunch of money on a rematch made for a rematch cause they
don't think Mayweather's going to happen.
Yes.
Mayweather's in jail right now.
Yeah.
And look if I eating.
From what I heard.
Oh really?
Like go on and look a hunger strike.
Yeah.
Like let me out of here.
I'm not going to,
I'm going to die.
Oh I can tell.
Look Real.
I have an am radio in my truck.
I went under a bridge halfway through that story.
I don't know.
That's hilarious.
That's what it sounded like.
Cause cause the,
the,
the prosecuting attorney was like,
well what do you think?
He's in prison.
This isn't the four seasons.
Well see this is how rumors get started in bars by shit heads like me who have
like fucking half the information they need and then they just start
pontificating to some on the Internet who's taken a couple of hits and then
you'll back me up.
Yeah,
totally.
Dude.
I'm telling you,
I said I'm just happy to be in the conversation.
Yeah Dude.
Yeah,
I bet that's exactly how they did it there.
You need to listen to the first half of it because you're freaking out about
your phone.
Well Bob,
I know that Bob Arum and Floyd Mayweather did not get along and Bob Arum was
Pascal's promoter and Floyd may with a tried to make some sort of a deal with
them but he didn't want to do 50 50 like they were having a hard time bargaining
it out.
But if I was a promoter and I was a crooked guy and I was trying to fix
something,
that would be like the perfect fight to fix because there's nobody else that's
interesting out there.
Now that Mayweather is in jail.
So who's,
who else is interesting for him to fight and if you were a mastermind,
if you,
if you want to put together a conspiracy,
I'm convinced.
Exactly it'll be brilliant.
Moneymaking move and you got to admire them really
now everybody wants to watch packy I'll get his revenge.
Exactly.
I mean I think the NBA is the same way.
I think they have their guys that they want in the ring.
They finesse it.
Yeah,
finesse.
And I also bet that pack yellows,
I bet there's probably some verbiage in his contract that changes,
you know,
how much money he gets based on whether or not he's a champion based on whether
or not he wins or loses.
I mean,
I would imagine,
did you,
did you something?
Maybe not.
It may the eat me.
He such a draw.
Maybe that's nonsense.
Why would they gamble?
Something like that.
I think that I,
I like your theory that they would try and keep it interesting.
I think that's exactly what I would do.
I was a corrupt guy.
I'm not saying that they did that,
but I'm saying,
look,
if I was like some dude in a Batman comic book that was manipulating,
I got this [inaudible] I don't,
I don't think it's like that
dude.
It's a business.
And you had,
you had a major asset,
just get taken off the table.
What can we do to keep excitement?
Keep it spicy going like that.
Yeah.
And I think like,
uh,
did you hear today on,
on Jim Rome,
he asked,
uh,
David Stern,
if,
if the,
the NBA lottery was fixed,
I know it doesn't mean shit to you.
What is the NBA lottery lottery is like,
basically in most sports,
if you had the worst record,
um,
when the draft comes around,
all the new talent comes out of college or whatever you get first pick.
So that way the worst teams can get better and it,
and it creates some sort of parity in theory,
keeps them,
you know,
um,
but the NBA,
to make it more exciting,
they have a lottery.
So like the,
the lower tan or whatever the fuck it is,
they all get,
uh,
the,
I'll get a shot at possibly being number one.
So then they put a bunch of ping pong balls into the thing and then they pull it
out.
Like I'd like the Massachusetts State fucking lottery.
Whoa.
And a,
they do that for whatever reason.
Like in some people think that they do it.
So every like three,
four years,
when there's a serious guy coming out who's going to be like a Paki out level
guy but like up like a basketball player,
um,
as far as like a drawing power of a Pacquiao and they have a major market that's
hurting,
they manipulate it where like,
you know,
they're going to,
like the first year they did it,
all of a sudden New York City,
which had the worst chance of winning it.
They want it.
And then they got Patrick Ewing,
which was great for hoop like that.
That's something if they do manipulate that,
I'm just thinking,
you know,
that's just a good business plan,
you know?
But anyway,
so this Guy Jim Rome asked him,
he asked him if it was fixed,
which is a fucking hilarious and insane question to ask the commissioner of
basketball.
Like he's going to be like,
yeah,
you know what it is.
But he asked it
right?
And,
and I guess Stern freaked out.
He's,
he said,
how could you even ask me that?
He said,
Joe,
let me ask you this.
He goes,
when did you stop beating your wife?
Whoa.
Takes that literal,
I guess that I know.
I never heard that,
that,
but I guess it's some old school,
um,
expression that they're there.
They're there.
What he's really doing is criticizing your question by saying what was,
when did you stop beating your wife?
Is the insinuation is that you're already beating your wife even if you're
totally innocent.
So Jim Rome didn't beat his wife,
right?
He,
he threw it at him like that saying,
that's what you're doing to me right now.
Wow.
What kind of headed the fucking Stanley Kubrick symbolism is that,
I don't know.
And once again,
I have not heard the audio.
Oh,
Jesus cry was driving over on my radio on the am radio going under bridges.
And this is what I heard.
This is all what I heard.
I heard they found Sasquatch.
Now this is the thing about me though.
I admit that I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
It cuts down on so many angry emails and it also makes people feel good about
themselves.
Most people think they're as full shit as I am,
but
they,
but they never have that honest moment with themselves.
Well,
you're full of shitness though.
Creates art.
Creates comedy,
you know?
Yeah.
By being the butt of the joke.
I know how it works.
I think.
I don't know how my,
how my bread's buttered.
I got my voice down.
I'm a fucking idiot.
I make people feel smarter than they really are.
I set the bar low,
Joe.
It's not a bad move.
I really like how you're rocking it.
Yeah.
I shouldn't be here.
I should have,
I should have died of an appendicitis in 1980 but they had enough medicine to
keep me going.
Um,
I'm one of the week,
Joe.
I shouldn't be here.
Oh,
one of the week.
Yeah.
I'm going to be how you feel be allowed.
I think that that's why like this sea of fucking morons that's out there,
that's what it is.
It's,
it's all the penicillin that's available.
If you just,
you just brought it back a little bit.
You know,
I think we'd have a lot more shiny stars out there.
You'd see people driving better if there was more disease.
If he just let the weak die off and I know I'm not gonna make the cut.
Well
I think there's only so much chicken.
There's only so much water out there.
We just weave out fucked all of it.
But that's it.
Terrible decision because it's,
it's often taught,
I mean there's,
there's a weird balance to the way life works.
And uh,
when you say the week,
often it's those weak that are inventing fucking imax and those are the ones
that are figuring out how to make your internet faster.
Four g phones,
they would have come up with that.
I don't think
you could leave those fucking sword swinging and dudes,
you could leave them alone for a million years.
Come back.
They'd still be hacking each other to death with swords.
No,
I'm not painting with one color here.
I'm saying the best of the best of the Imax guys.
The best of the best of the,
the,
the guys who will beat you down.
I think that the Dream Team,
a few would be eggs is what I'm talking about.
He had
what,
what I'm saying is the physically weak often are the most
people when they fucking aliens show up.
The guys who got actually an actual game plan,
those are the guys who were going to figure out how not to get on that space
ship and get eaten.
And isn't this obvious joke,
this is,
I'm done.
If I was looking right down the street here,
I was living in another planet.
I want a food source.
People would be a good one.
You know,
we're like fucking rats on a sinking ship where everywhere.
I know,
and I would come here for we,
we would be like a nice steak house with all the fat,
marble people.
We'd be the best.
Well fed grass instead of corn fed.
It'd be like this one's from Texas.
Some Houston would be like the Colby beef people would at beach.
This is 100% Vegan Diet.
Got The guy ate nothing but plants.
Nothing but plants.
That would be,
yeah,
that would be like the uh,
at a mommy of human beings if you ate one of those guys.
Cannibalism.
Everybody on the Joe Rogan experience.
Well,
we know the chimps eat monkeys.
Chimps eat fucking assholes about it.
I hate chimps.
Can't stand a man.
I watched his fucking to champion this chip.
Rip This fucking,
they had this dad,
this whole thing.
I know you've seen this.
You watch all of this shit.
They will basically,
I don't know what they did.
They sort of trap.
Yeah,
they steer that one.
And they had,
they had the infrared thing where that you could see where the chips were going
and they had really scary.
Yeah.
It's like they chased them down the street except it was in trees and they had
to have their Tufts hang in there and they basically drove this monkey bait
right into the trap and this fucking chimp grabs him.
He's standing on his back and rather than just twisted his head and in his
misery,
he just starts digging into his back,
pulling pieces out of them.
And this fucking monkeys,
it's gone.
I
just freaking out and this fucking thing is just sitting there like biting on
its hips.
I remember that.
He's like biting on his hip to the monkey screaming it.
It's a little eyes are like bugging out of his head.
It's dark and that's it.
Fucking says relatives and just like us,
they're fucking evil,
man.
I'd shoot a chimp dude.
I ain't know if you saw in the wild.
No,
no,
no.
If he's right up to him,
fuck you.
Yeah.
This is for the monkey.
Not on this certain animals.
I could kill.
I would be after one set person got their face ripped off by a chimp.
Oh,
I would be like a trigger.
Happy Cop.
Well,
that lady,
she was given that chimpanzees Xanax.
That's crazy.
She was given Xanax and wine.
I used to get my cat Flonase because it's Persian and always had breathing
problems and I was really stoned.
I'm like,
I'll just put a little drop on the tip of her nose and I'm like,
that's probably the dumbest thing.
You could probably do it once.
It's explained to me.
I've never tried Zeiss.
Soon it's the fuck is this stuff's bad for human son even called now I don't.
You still have one like that.
Five hour energies and liquid coke.
I need a nap now.
I want to work all night.
You know what that is mostly,
it's a lot of vitamin B 12 so having that much caffeine though,
those five hour,
our energies are actually healthier,
like on a chemical profile level than it is to dry.
I read that day Starbucks,
they are insane levels of everything that's good for you,
which is never good.
Well,
it's a little bit at one glass of alcohol is good for you.
You're not 12 chunks.
You pissed that out.
None of those.
You have to worry about it.
It's not like you're drinking them all day every day and you're going to develop
toxic amounts of vitamins.
Once again,
Joe,
I haven't read a book that I've already made up my mind.
It's liquid.
Coq fucking stuff will kill you.
You know?
Do you remember that there was some shit called red line.
Did you ever try red line?
It's one of those things.
Any of that shit it say like three servings or something.
I Dunno,
this I'm making up.
I don't know if it said three servers.
Your car underneath a bridge.
You're in my arena arena because I don't want to get sued.
I don't know.
It read,
lot of people pissed at me,
but it was the strongest fucking caffeinated beverage I've ever had in my life.
Like I remember drinking one,
I was tired and I was driving back from some gig and I got one at like one of
those 24 marks at a gas station and I sounded fucking drink.
That's the wheel and I'm on my
way home and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I am wide awake.
I'm thinking all this shit I'm going to do back when I get home.
I gotta clean my fucking office.
Jesus Christ.
I could still get a workout in if I put an hour and a half cleaning and then I
do an hour of kettle bells.
I'm thinking all this shit.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm,
I'm Mike on Crank right now.
Essentially on some,
some liquid amphetamine,
any of those sports drinks,
energy drinks,
anything.
It's fizzy.
I don't fuck with the cloth.
Let less,
it's like a root beer or a coke or something like that.
I'll do that shit.
Okay.
Oh,
speaking of that,
can I,
can I plug something?
I tell them going,
doing something for the Oakland A's.
They got root beer float Dale Day,
I swear to God.
And it's to raise awareness for childhood diabetes.
Swear to God,
I guess a long time ago,
uh,
the root beer company,
they,
this was their cause and they were into it and I guess there was no irony back
in the day.
So they are the ones,
they are the ones.
So I already know,
I already know.
I already,
everybody in my Twitter thought that they were the most clever person ever.
Like I didn't notice how ridiculous it is to how funny it is.
I think it's kind of funny.
I think it's awesome.
Stop.
Galpo you know,
come on down.
Open Bar let's,
and alcoholism,
you know,
it's just something,
there's something,
what I like about it,
there's something almost like anchorman,
like old school about it that I love it.
So,
uh,
I'm going to go up there and plus,
you know,
being a baseball fan of the way it used to be,
where teams like the pirates in the A's were good before all this,
you know,
the money markets one,
the money markets,
one big business,
including the red sox.
Like,
I mean,
Roger Clemens,
they said that he's there.
He's still getting tried.
He's going to try it again for something now.
Yeah.
But then none of that shit's about steroids.
It's about a perjury perjuring yourself and has about steroids,
steroids.
But it's really,
you lied under oath.
It's,
it's a sense the Clinton thing where it wasn't the blow job.
It's that you said you didn't get one under oath.
He swore that you would tell the truth.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
they're going after the dude for,
for doing steroids in baseball.
Leave the bankers.
That is fine.
Leave those guys alone.
That's okay.
But this mother fucker trying to claim he's got 300 victories.
That's amazing.
We got to stop this.
How strange is that?
It isn't,
it doesn't hurt worse.
But I mean in 2012,
they would waste any time on that.
The fact that it got congress,
Congress,
they had congressional hearings.
I don't send them a base.
Everybody gives a fuck about baseball.
You got a mobbed up ref.
The fucking NBA is able able to handle that in house.
And it was just tearing my rights,
see lane and go fuck yourself.
Let's go.
A game's at seven.
And this stuff here,
like they,
they uh,
for some reason they had to get involved.
I don't know why.
I don't fucking read.
I don't know what's going on.
I really don't.
I have no idea.
It's so,
I never noticed like how truly uninformed I am until I get behind a microphone,
because I always just hear the audience going like,
dude,
that isn't how it is.
And it's just fucking ridiculous fucking dude.
It is so fucking ridiculous that I've been able to,
to earn a living and be able
to eat three times a day with just the unbelievable lack of fucking information
that I have that you just act like an idiot and strip malls around the country.
Yeah.
But there's a beauty in that.
There's a beauty in that lack of information.
That's the weed talking.
No,
there's a beautiful comedy.
It's a beauty in it.
That's a,
that's your,
that's your thing that's driving me nuts the whole time.
Oh,
I see.
I thought this was added prosthetics to this fucking cat's head for cats had
broke when it moved in here.
That was the first thing that broke with my favorite.
Okay.
Are you a cat person?
I used to be until recently.
Now I can't,
I,
I'm done with all animals.
I think this,
they're,
they're just there.
You have to give them too much attention and I,
I don't have that.
Time would be good.
He gets it like,
you know,
we asked like the loners man,
go fuck yourself.
Oh you have company when I need you.
Yeah.
You think that,
but you know,
if it's,
that's a needy basically.
Yeah.
My cats are getting the older they get.
My cat is super neat when I'm trying to write now ma'am now tries to get in my
lap all the time and I'll give her like a little bit and try to send her on her
way.
But after a while I'm like,
come on,
I got to right.
Leave me alone.
Stop.
Yeah,
not well cat's out of the room.
You have to take her out of the room and shut the door.
Got scabs.
That Voodoo vibe.
Yeah.
Like well they know the date you're going to die.
They have like look in there.
They're definitely different.
I would not,
I would not be surprised if cats couldn't see some shit that we can't see.
Know some shit that we can't know.
They say that animals are the ones that know when earthquakes are coming,
they start fucking freaking out and they run up hill.
Like when the tsunami came,
no animals died in that shit or not.
No animal style.
Very few animals died like regular animals like deers and shit.
Cause they all ran away.
They all knew it was coming.
They,
they feel like they have,
they have senses that we don't need.
We've,
we've vice gifts because there aren't that.
They're barefoot.
Get on their horse thinking it.
They can feel the rumbling.
You sitting there and your flip flops,
that rubber,
that's all you need.
That little half inch or rubber.
Yeah.
And you're not going to fill a Sufi,
nope.
No barefoot guy died.
Not Tsunami though.
That's true.
Lasting people heard before that wave crash was the slap of humans
running by them.
It's true.
Remember that kind of your central,
that dog bait,
this video when that dog heard the earthquake?
No,
I don't think I know this.
There's no sound to this.
I don't believe.
How the fuck can we prove it by watching?
Could hear the door for example.
Uh,
I don't,
it's in 2010.
Uh,
we can find out in a sec,
but is this Japan?
Uh,
no,
but see the dog runs
okay.
And then watch.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Whoa.
This is scary as fuck.
Here's another view of the dog just running.
Huh?
Dogs just like go fuck yourself.
Go look at all those cars.
Move outside.
Yeah.
This is such dumb place to live.
We live with the dumbest place ever.
We're just rolling the dice and hoping that the,
the ground does it open up and swallow the city while we're here.
Yeah,
but it's all every place.
It's dumb.
Yeah,
it's true.
Yeah.
This is going to be so you live out in the middle of nowhere.
Then some grizzly bear can come and eat your face.
Have you been watching mountain men?
But I,
I,
I have the [inaudible] out your window.
Cello.
I have the utmost respect
for fucking rednecks in,
in mountain men and people who could just live off the land.
Green Berets just fucking drop them in the middle of nowhere and they can just
get a fire going and just live out there and like the egg,
you should know how to do that.
There's a mountain man show up is a fascinating show.
It's a bunch of guys.
They live in different parts of the country,
all of them in the mountains.
One guy runs his whole farm and he uh,
puts on classes and teaches people how to survive,
trains people how to survive in the wilderness so that you could live off the
land,
shows you how to plant Kale,
shows you how to hunt deer.
So she had to make like homemade deer stands and he's doing all this shit.
And another guy is living up in Montana and this mother fucker has a gigantic
grizzly bear that's stalking his house and they see this thing,
they got this thing on film and they're,
they're shining a light on,
it's fucking enormous and it's just wandering around his yard that the
footprints this thing the next day and their shoot meets a fucking giant bear
and it's hungry cause it's starting to get snowy and he wants to hibernate but
it doesn't have any food in his stomach.
So go get him some fucking sandwiches,
have a big bag of raw meat out there.
Let them get the itis and you want to let know the heel,
chow that down,
we'll get sleepy.
You can never do that if you feed a bear.
They always remember where they got it from when they come back for more.
Nah,
that's an urban myth.
I started by those park rangers.
Just trying to get some press.
You know what I wanted to watch.
Tweets are coming in now.
Fuck you bill burr.
You don't even respect animals.
Unfollow.
I love that.
Like I give a shit that's my favorite.
Oh the fuck out of me.
I like the threat that I'm going to unfollow you dude.
As you have one more sports text,
I'm going to unfollow you.
Really Fall,
follow.
Go ahead and follow through with it.
I want to see that,
that show where the uh,
the,
the uh,
the people who are preparing for the apocalypse.
Yeah.
What is that?
I wanted to watch that because I think that show was,
that's another,
that's another thing that you're,
you're an idiot until it goes down.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You look like a nut until the guy was sticks.
The money in the mattress is a fucking idiot.
Because what if someone breaks into the house and then the banking system
collapses,
right.
No problem.
Album
is not going to be storing food and and containing water cause you could do
that.
You could store food and water and likely you could ride it out for like a
couple of months or so.
The real problem is going to be your neighbor probably didn't do that.
That's going to be the real problem.
The other people that are you clothes that were poor that will live in day to
day and check to check what the fuck are they going to do when the food stops
coming in,
that's when the real problem kicks in.
So it might not help that you have a lot of water.
No.
That's why your plant your food in the backyard,
you don't advertise it by being in the front.
Yes.
Everyone's going to see
yard in the middle of the night and stealing out of vegetables is,
is link up with your other paranoid neighbors.
This is like a great beginning to a fucking movie,
right?
You fucking,
they link.
You got like three of four paranoid families on one block and when the shit goes
down,
my house is the rally point and we,
we fight off all these other suckers and meanwhile we're bringing a Bundt cakes
and everything's fucking cool.
Right?
I only got the first 10 pages.
Don't look at me like this is going to go all the way through the [inaudible]
script.
Who shaves name?
Who?
Shane black.
Shane.
I don't know.
Yeah.
So then,
and then a famous a screenplay car.
It's like Red Dawn.
We got to kill your classmate except it's your a,
your fucking your neighbor.
Somebody pees and it will radiate or I don't know.
Oh,
flushing
involved in Syria and they're selling Syria these giant attack planes.
That's awesome.
They were talking about this and the news that uh,
now serious going to have these crazy Russian attack.
Calyx
copters can be honest.
None of that scares me anymore.
Really.
I have given into the fact that this is our destiny.
Our destiny is that we are going to fuck ourselves over.
And uh,
you know,
you can only die once.
You just hope you're not.
You don't have a chip on your back and your hip like that's not going to go out
that way.
But yeah,
you want to shoot some shit at me and fucking,
you know,
blow me to smithereens.
How long am I going to give a fuck for?
I'm just going to be like for like half a second.
It's over.
Hopefully.
What if you get your legs blown off and then you have to live as a prisoner of
war?
I bleed out.
How do you know he'd be able to bleed out?
What am I going to push my legs up against the frying managed and try to
cauterize the,
is that the right word?
But sometimes they get fused from the blast.
I have.
No,
there's no way.
I talked about this on my podcast like I,
if I was ever faced with like that challenge,
I don't know I could do that,
but if I was neck down,
there's no way.
There's no way.
I would just sit there and I would be gone along with everybody.
He baked.
Wow.
He's so positive.
I learned how to steer my own wheelchair with my tongue and the first chance
daylight I got at a staircase,
I just fucking steer it right over.
I set myself write down,
there's no way.
There's no fucking way I could.
I couldn't like people who do that and they get naked writer write a book or the
most amazing human beings in the planet because there's no way I could,
I would pass that test.
Hawkings has the craziest situation.
Huh?
Guy in a wheelchair,
can't even talk,
can't,
can barely move his hand to communicate and he scrolls through words.
He has some method of,
of doing that and then this thing reads what he says.
That's it says it out loud.
Being believable.
Yeah.
And he's like,
I got top scientists should have died after the appendicitis.
I'm one of the week.
I just did.
It's just no way.
He's like one of the rare guys that took three Jiu Jitsu.
I tapped out for good.
I'm out.
You should come.
Come,
come with me tonight man.
Look,
I know I'm not a man would love it.
I need to go down there and have it reinforced all you guys get fresher side.
Is it a calm me down and make you feel better
dude,
I'm like the commerce I've been in my life.
I'm always going to sound like I'm in a bad mood because I have the east coast
accent.
Right?
Look dude,
your fucking phony.
Calm down.
You're like,
you're,
you're you,
you smoke weed.
Why calm down from exercise to weed doesn't necessarily calm me down as it does
make me just a little more sensitive.
Red Ban.
You buying this?
Do you think we'd calmed me down?
Uh,
yeah dude,
you are a completely different person.
Like when I met you in like 96 97 you are good guy,
but you wouldn't have the most intense fucking dude's I never met.
It was like this switch somewhere in your life was flipped and the shit was on.
I don't even know how you slept.
I would like you are like a fucking goal line defense middle linebacker.
That's shit doesn't mean anything to you.
I'm using sports analogies like you were fucking intense too.
And every story I heard about you at Taekwondo,
uh,
events.
I believed all of it after meeting you for like literally about 25 seconds.
Well,
I,
I was transitioning then still.
That was still just a few weeks.
You sound like a guy trying to mix the role.
No,
it's true.
He was transgender when I was a,
a young guy.
Crazy.
Or when I was younger,
I was going through my entire,
my entire childhood was spent competing in martial arts tournaments from the
time I was like 15 to the time I was 22 was my last fight.
So do you think it made you like that or it tapped into something that was
already there?
I don't think I would have been that intense if I didn't have to deal with
really dangerous shit on a regular basis.
It was the fact that you were fighting in tournament's on a regular basis and
nothing ever happened to me.
I never got hurt,
but I easily could've easily,
could have zigged when I should have zagged and got knocked the fuck out.
It just never happened.
I only lost once in a kickboxing match.
And that was not,
not that I didn't lose a before and taekwondo but lost once by stoppage.
The only time I ever got stopped was in a kickboxing match.
There was a third fight in a day and I was terrible nutrition back then,
always getting sick,
you know,
it didn't really take vitamins and shit and I was on the fence back then.
I was like doing standup and fighting at the same time so it wasn't like a bad
knock out.
I got dropped by a left hook and then I got up and my legs just wouldn't work
and he hit me again and I fell down again.
They stopped the fight.
It was just a,
he had hit my jaw like in the perfect spot and everything gave out and I was
thinking about it like when I was,
when I was going back that there's one of two things I'm going to do.
Either I'm going to go fucking crazy now and rededicate myself and try to be a
world champion kickboxer and just use the fact that I got tired in the third
fight of the day as motivation to just run extra miles and do extra plyometrics
and do extra rounds or be a standup.
Yeah,
no brainer.
It's a no brainer.
It's like I can't,
there's no way.
There's no reward in that.
There was no ultimate fighting championship back then.
There was no,
so it's like I had to reprogram my brain.
I ended up pro my,
my brain was used to always thinking about martial arts competition.
That's all it was.
It was dodging kicks,
landing your own,
you know,
getting in,
closing the distance and you know,
and forcing your game plan.
That's what my whole day was spent fighting in my head.
Even if I wasn't finding I'd be fighting in my head what I was when I was a,
like I had girlfriends,
we,
they'd sleep over and I would,
I would throw kicks in the middle of the night like,
like my whole body would jolt like a kick because I was having a fighting dream
so I was terrified.
I was constantly terrified.
I got really good at it because I was absolutely horrified of it.
I just didn't want to,
I just did not want to get my ass kicked and I was already doing it.
I'm like,
well,
if this is what we're doing,
then we've got to get really fucking good at this because this is not something
you can half ass dudes are kicking dudes in the face and knocking people
unconscious conscious like this is fucking terrifying.
I saw it happen so many times,
saw it happen to good friends.
I saw it happen to people who are better than me.
They just fought the wrong dude at the wrong time,
which easily could have happened to me.
It didn't,
but it easily could have like a,
our instructor never protected us at all.
He put us even,
we were like,
kids were teenagers.
He would put us in the men's division and you know,
and tell you like,
you're good enough to fight as a black belt when you were like a blue belt or
red belt.
He was just,
he wanted to see who is crazy.
He wants to see,
he wanted to develop a team of people who didn't give a fuck.
That's so funny that you could do that with kids.
Like that guy.
He would be on the,
the like at the very least local news,
you know,
it was very cultish though.
The martial arts schools are very cultish.
It's,
yes sir.
No Sir.
It's all like almost military,
you know,
like it's always bowing when you see him.
You know this,
you always bow.
You always call him,
sir.
It was very,
I can,
I never been able to exist in that dynamic.
I don't,
no matter what it was like,
there's no way I could,
uh,
I needed it.
I grew up without a dad.
I grew up without a,
I have a Stepdad,
but my real dad,
I knew he was alive and I didn't communicate with them,
so it always fucked with me.
So I needed some sort of intense discipline to get my shit together.
So the first time I ever felt like I had any control of my life at all was when
I started doing martial arts.
I was like,
oh,
finally,
I can fucking get good at something at this.
I'm good at this shit.
You know?
But so that's why I was so wound.
You first met.
It took me a while to relax.
You know,
if you're trying to be the best in the world,
kick a people in the face.
That's it.
Tents,
pursuit.
The few,
the few fighters that I have met,
most of them,
and I always felt,
it's like they
already proved that they are fucking guy's guy in the ring.
That when they're hanging around,
they're just relaxed.
They don't want,
they don't want any problems.
Most of them are really tired from training to,
you know,
when,
when you're a fighter,
you know,
man,
when you're not training.
I never thought challenge.
I just always thought like,
Hey,
I just knocked the guy out on television,
no ring wearing no shirt.
Just like bloodsport I kicked the fuck out of this guy.
I don't give a shit about you and your dockers.
Go ahead and talk shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Like I always felt,
I always felt like that vibe.
So I always felt that they were,
uh,
after I met a couple,
it's like,
oh,
these guys,
yeah,
they chill.
They don't have anything
walking around.
Definitely that too.
Definitely that they don't have anything to prove.
The worst part about being a man is dealing with dickheads,
you know?
And the less dick heads that,
like the smallest amount of dickheads in the world that I operate in is guys at
the gym.
Nicest guys.
My,
when I go to Jujitsu class,
the fucking everybody in the class is nice.
There's no dickheads.
None.
Everybody's just training hard,
doing their thing and it's fun.
I think there's,
it's way easier to be a nice guy when you know how to fight.
It's just way easier.
It removes a big thing that fucks with a lot of dudes so easy.
If you don't know how to fight like me,
if you just just be nice,
be nice to you,
I believe fuck with you.
I believe in being nice to,
it's not like people fuck with me.
I really get away with very little fucking with most people are really nice to
me.
People say,
oh,
he's a weird,
like people coming up to you that you know,
you don't know them.
They know.
You know,
most of the Times they're just being nice like 99.999% of the time they're being
nice,
you know?
So,
but I'd rather be the guy who can defend himself,
you know?
Then a guy who worries about some weird fucking person doing something to them.
I don't want to plant any theory season
me,
I don't relevantly Bev,
isn't it?
I've got a live in a house now and ever since I've lived in a house,
now this is something fucking unsettling about that where it's just you in that
they come to,
someone comes in,
they're getting you.
Whereas like an apartment building,
there's like,
there's a bunch of options.
It's like a buffet.
You know,
apartment building thing is weird too,
because you don't know what the fuck these people are up to.
You know,
who knows what that guy,
where's this money?
But I know where you live,
so if you're gonna do something,
you have to fuck with your neighbor because we're too though,
isn't it?
When you're like,
you know,
you look at each other like across the hall,
Hey,
I ain't doing,
you shut your door.
And he shuts his fucking door to his leg.
He's sleeping right there.
He's like feet away from you or he moves out and then you feel like a loser days
going to a better building that never,
that never moving back home.
They're always going,
always going,
moving on.
I remember put Patrice talk about that.
Uh,
he used to talk about how people moving out of,
uh,
when he was young,
when he would see neighbors moving away,
he would always be looking out the window,
all sad.
He would get like depressed.
Like,
I don't know why I,
we used to laugh our asses off talking about that kind of shit.
Just picture a big tree.
So it was sad,
bummed out.
Yeah.
Like some sort of Christmas episode or something.
Uh,
I lived in a real cheap apartment complex in revere when I was first moving on
out on my own.
I lived with a girl there and uh,
I remember it was really cheap.
It was a shady place.
It was thought it was not good.
Right.
That was one of those.
And all these fucking people be cooking weird shit.
He would walk down the hallway,
he'd smell all kinds of weird ethnic food.
It was just very strange.
Like the aromas of food was so potent and poor neighborhoods,
you know,
like it's very rare you walk into like a real high end apartment complex and you
smell something like fucking like
Goulash,
intense spices.
Someone's fucking making fish head soup.
You know what's funny is I can hear that metal door slamming in echo when I
first apartment and I lived in in New York when I would walk in and there's just
that overwhelming smell of somebody's cooking some fucking cow's head.
They got a market.
Me and Bobby used to,
he used to live together and this place in the upper east side with this
Nigerian Dooney came home one day with all this fucking meat dead he had bought
or whatever and being cooked,
Bobby Selman Bob Eight it kind of tasted a little gamey where he's like,
what is this?
And he just was like,
he was like,
it's cow.
He goes,
I know what kind he's cow.
Like,
I don't know what he was eating a hook.
It was just,
it wasn't like
part of the cheek or something.
I don't know what the fuck he was eating,
but it was the weirdest looking,
the texture of it.
I didn't fuck with it.
That's when I,
Bobby should have known that he had some sort of food issue or he was starving
because he said,
fuck it.
I'll,
you know,
Bobby's a more open dude anyway,
so he was like,
yeah,
I'll try the shit.
And I looked at it,
as I say,
I'm a fucking with that.
That looks like a,
that's like a tree stump
muscle avail.
Rump roast.
He pukes easy easily,
doesn't he?
Does he,
isn't he like,
I have like a gag thing where he just starts puking nonstop.
If he hears something like,
you know,
I've never know.
I think he does because remember like Jimmy pulled his,
uh,
he had his belly button.
He came in his belly button,
he put his finger in his belly button.
He's making people smell it.
I smelled it.
And why this?
Cause I wanted to know.
Oh,
I wanted to know what it smelled like.
What it tastes like.
Taste or you're silly bitch.
That's the most disgusting.
I did smell it though.
I gotta tell you though.
The guy asked me if I wanted to smell it.
You know,
right there.
I don't want to be rude.
The closest I ever came to puking,
uh,
in public,
like that was on the opiate.
Anthea.
Oh,
you were fucking there?
Yeah.
Oh my God,
no before that,
that they,
when they had that the egg,
the egg drinking contest,
that to this day is the most fucked up thing sane I've ever seen.
And it was absolutely brilliant.
And uh,
it was,
uh,
Nathaniel,
he named you.
You were the one who said the only thing they can top that is if somebody leaned
back and open their mouth and had somebody puke into it.
So you,
you had the idea and then Nathaniel name that the baby bird called it the baby
birds made it,
that that made it because think about,
do you ever seen a baby bird get fed by its mother?
The mother essentially like opens his mouth.
He's like fucking JAKKS in the kid's mouth.
Ah,
it's so hard to watch.
It's so glorious.
You know,
I told that story like three days later,
but tell the whole story.
Some people,
the people that it was an egg,
it was an eggnog drinking contest.
Have you ever had,
even if you like Eggnog,
Eggnog is fucking disgusting.
Unbelievably sugary and heavy and a dude.
Every time I tell a story,
I start to gag.
Oh,
I haven't told it a while.
It's incredible story.
So basically what you had to do was you had to do a double shot of eggnog every
30 seconds.
So once a minute.
What was it was a number?
I don't know.
Yeah,
it was like every,
every few seconds.
I don't remember what it was like once.
It couldn't be once a minute because he had 72 shots.
So it couldn't have been once a minute.
No,
he didn't know he was up to 40 something.
Really?
I don't remember who the fuck do I want to say?
No you wouldn't.
You might be ready.
Yeah,
let's just watch it.
That's the great Pat Duffy.
Get rid of this.
I remember this young man's name.
Easily an intern.
I remember his name.
Laura Savage,
sir.
Cause I can 73 73 thank you.
Thank you.
How's the memory kids 73 yeah.
So anyway,
pat from Munafiki is,
by the way,
a diabetic who lost a toe to the disease.
So he has to get this out.
It's right after comes in and it starts going and he's,
Oh my God,
I,
when it comes out,
it comes out in giant pumps at first,
but then after a while it comes out cartoonish.
That's card two ways.
That is cartoonish.
That's
cartoons.
It's insane.
The sheer volume is insane.
Guys,
the Peter North to throw up.
Oh my God,
that is the most fucked up.
Can't top that,
but that was the greatest moment and only opie and Anthony will be fucking crazy
to have to do something like that.
That was amazing.
It was genius.
I've only been watching a ted talk version this whole time.
I just never really watched the real version.
I've always been watching the POW talk virgin.
It's so much better quality.
Oh yeah.
There's a couple of different cameras in the room.
Huh?
I told that story like three days later.
Hook in his fucking head and that's insane.
Check it out and Opie and anthony.com if that's still going to try to clean his
head off.
Didn't even have a shower for this young man.
It was the craziest thing I've ever seen.
The greatest moment of radio history because it was just so,
what are the stars aligned with a guy who's 300 fucking pounds.
He could drink the 73 shots of egg nog
this,
there's no morning show has ever even come close to that.
Nothing in the neighborhood.
And then just the stars aligning with this Pat Duffy character being so
incredibly insane.
He had already built his way up to it.
He rushed to the shit that that led up to that there was all those funny
nicknames we had.
There was the one guy,
he would take the shot and then when someone would go to Puke,
because basically we didn't,
we didn't explain last person to not puke wins.
So what would happen was people be getting full of Eggnog and you're not going
to puke.
But then someone would puke,
which would make you feel,
so this fucking guy,
every time someone would go to Puke,
he would walk three steps away and just face the wall.
We started calling them Blair witch
and then there was another guy who already puked and he puked into like a
fucking uh,
I don't know like what do you call it?
The thank you,
you your pour like picture a picture he puked into that then poured it on fruit
loops and would start eating his own puke Froot loops to make other people puke.
That was the terrorist
because he used to taking people out with them and I just thought to with so
many,
and then I also remember terrorists is just taking people out and then there was
pat full Munafiki the champion and after he won he kept drinking and we were
like,
like a true champion.
He's only competing with themselves and he just,
he put to wreck it are like,
he crushed the record.
He crushed it.
That was,
that had to be like a gallon of Eggnog
but yet it was like,
you look at these rates,
double shots.
What I mean,
well he's,
he's not lying and not online.
If you go and watch it,
you will not believe that.
What is the value?
The video you just played,
what version is I use a bunch of them.
Yeah.
I just went to youtube and typed in opie and Anthony,
uh,
baby bird.
Baby bird is the first one.
Don't do the Pao talkers and that one's the bad quality version.
Okay.
One right below eggnog champion.
Most incident,
you know,
just say,
so I've been trying to tell us I want to,
I told,
uh,
at Nia had one of her friends over and I was telling the story dude,
and I was laying on the floor crying,
laughing,
retelling the story.
It's like three days later,
wild gagging.
And I remembered me as friend was horrified.
She finally says,
where did they get these people?
And that's what sent me over the top.
I was like,
I was like crying,
like I don't know.
And that was it.
And I,
I almost puked.
Like what if I actually went into detail and went to tell that story?
I would start gagging again.
I don't think I ever won't gag telling that story.
That was the most disgusting thing.
And the amount of people on the staff who everybody gets to appoint one of
people who puked.
Oh yeah.
The smell of fucking stomach lining the hell it was,
I know he's good.
That's my Sunday night.
I just got to,
I'm now finally over that,
but I had food poisoning and it fucking ruined my life.
I it,
that's a great way to lose 10 pounds listening.
And it's true.
I did.
I did lose about nine pounds.
Uh,
for,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's not good dude.
You gotta be careful.
You gotta be careful what your Sushi song and I can't even eat now.
It makes me even feel nauseous.
You shouldn't use it as a time to get like in great shape.
Yeah.
I've been eating watermelon.
Where did you eat Sushi?
[inaudible] or whatever.
It's caught at Glendale Americana or whatever.
And that's a decent place.
Right?
That's a nice place.
But sushi people were like,
dude,
what the fuck you eat Sushi on a Sunday?
Never do that.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
it was happy hour Sushi Sunday on.
That's probably the,
that's the worst time to go cause cause it's Friday Sushil fish.
Yeah.
Getting rid of it.
I never thought about that.
Why not have a seven day fish market?
I don't know that.
I guess that's the thing.
Sunday Sushi.
I'd like to get Gordon Ramsey on the case.
It's so amazing how we've been able to cut that out of our lives.
That whole food gathering nonsense.
Like while I was watching this mountain men show,
watch this poor guy with she rodeo knees.
He's going out and looking for deer,
like trying to get a deer,
some meat for the freezer.
All he's looking for bears constantly like what
change of life it's happened when they figured out how to cut out that whole
gathering food that was already bad enough.
Bad knees looking for a deer and then he does the the over the top wild looking
for bears.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
You got to watch the show.
Great show.
No,
that's why I just watched it last night for the first time.
I'm comfortable being in the Matrix.
I,
you know,
I'll,
I'll starve to death.
It will be a brutal month and then that'll be it.
I don't want to be walking around with my bad back out in the fucking book,
trying to shoot deer in the face,
trying to gut it with some sharpened stick.
All right.
I'm,
I'm part of the week.
I'm not supposed to be here.
That's just someone like you.
You'll,
you'll tap back into your,
uh,
when you through kicks in at night.
I'll just grow.
Look at mountain man beard.
That's where animal skins make my own spears.
I just,
that's the name of good Bruce Springsteen album.
Make,
make my own spirit.
When I throw kicks in the night
two kicks
chicks,
it has to be like a breakup margin.
It's something about being young and getting out of the town and getting away
from all the boozers and then you go to the chorus kicks in the night
I would split,
he's still write songs.
So Bruce Springsteen still out there.
Right?
I have to see that guy live cause Jim Norton's finally the guy will put me over
the top because Jim was yet another guy who I don't want to speak for him,
but he didn't seem like he was a fan.
And then saw him live and was just like,
dude,
you got to see this guy alive.
He's just fucking sad.
I just,
it's as a performer.
You got to go see the guy.
Yeah,
that's what Brian Cowen was saying.
That dude's like in his sixties,
he does full back bends and slides on his knees on stage.
Just like,
you know,
he's like,
he's in fucking tremendous shape.
Three and a half hour show.
I did a standup show and he was one of the acts on it.
It's what a good what?
Yeah.
Sickest lineup ever.
I did a thing called,
I know I was told us on like 20 different podcasts,
but it's a great story.
I was a,
I did this,
this standup for the troops.
It's this great benefit.
Um,
it was at the beacon theater and this was the lineup was the Max Weinberg Band
was,
was the playing the music in between the acts and beforehand and after hand.
Jon Stewart hosted a first act out of the gate was Tony Bennett.
Then it was uh,
uh,
Bruce Springsteen.
Then they auctioned off one of Bruce Springsteen's guitar.
Went for like a hundred grand.
Then Joe Mchale had to follow that somehow did that then me and then Seinfeld.
Oh my,
that was the show.
It was insane.
And I remember looking over,
you know,
waiting,
didn't want to go over cause that's like Jerry,
it is the king.
I don't wanna Piss the guy.
And I looked over and it was literally like backlit with his suit on like Jerry
ready to go out on stage.
It was like fucking iconic and it was looking over like going,
I'm at the beacon theater and that's Jerry Seinfeld,
right?
They're going to go on next.
One of the great,
great nights,
uh,
of being in this businessman.
But I saw Bruce Springs sang one song.
He was jumping all around.
I was on the piano and everything and I was just like,
wow,
this guys,
I can't do that.
This guy's got 25 years on me.
What song was it?
I Dunno.
I never got into his stuff.
So were you the first guy to do stand up on the show?
Mchale John Mchale.
Did Joe had to,
yeah,
he's a good dude,
man.
I did that.
Great Guy.
He's a great guy.
Really Nice Guy.
It's,
it's nice to know there's still nice guys out there like you meet people,
you know,
hang out with them.
Most people are,
the ACG vast percentage in our business are in comparison to the way people
think of us.
People think of Comedians is being like,
comedians are always miserable to hate life.
They're really only funny when they're on stage.
There's a lot of stereotypes that go along with being,
and a lot of them is
a lot of truth in that for a while.
Some,
but the vast majority,
you were miserable for a while.
Yeah.
And we'll lay dead.
Just,
you know
what happens in your late twenties and early thirties when you don't think
you're a psycho and you're not,
you don't think you're out of your mind.
And then you realize,
oh,
wait a minute and I'm completely out of my fucking mind.
I'm just,
you know,
you,
you know what you just walking around saying hello to people.
Hi,
how are Ya?
Nice to meet Ya.
You know,
paying your bills on time and you think you're,
you're normal and a that all of a sudden,
you know,
if some shit happens and you're like,
Oh fuck,
I'm this guy.
I need to work on this,
need to work on that.
And uh,
you know,
hopefully you make the right choices by the time you get to your late thirties.
I know.
This is just how it happened for me.
I started like
level and out and being like,
alright,
what am I going to be angry the rest of my fucking life?
I certainly do though too.
You know what I mean?
Pot can't be 100% to blame for me calming down,
but uh,
no,
the devil comes that point.
You're either going to steer it into the wall.
Oh,
you're going to,
is going to try to chill a little bit.
But yeah,
getting back to the other thing though,
this,
there's just way too many talented fucking people in this business for you too.
I feel to,
even if you were a dick to get away with it for,
because all they're waiting for is that first project you do to flop.
They just looking for,
I mean that they're going to hang with you a while.
He,
while you're making them money.
But I,
well there are a lot of people that are decks and you know,
and then they stop working.
I mean that,
I've have friends that are directors and tell me horror stories about having to
work with some crazy lady who yells at them the set and you know,
w demands changes to our character because the character wouldn't do this.
And I'm like,
my God,
we've got to get through this fucking season with her and then they gonna kill
her off me.
Cause like they tell you stories about shit like that and you're like,
God,
this business,
you can get away with that for a little while.
But like all,
you know,
not very often that the next few was getting off the bus every day.
You know what I mean?
If you're just going to go the performer route,
so there's always going to be somebody younger,
fresher face,
whatever.
So you can't,
I dunno,
I dunno how you survive doing,
doing it the other way.
So
I've yet to be on anything.
I mean,
I'm done a lot of acting stuff,
but everybody,
everything I've ever done it,
everybody has been unbelievably nice.
Yeah.
But we all know guys,
especially comics that are kind of cons.
Yeah.
But how far did they get?
Some get pretty far.
They get,
dude,
you killing me.
I was thinking there was a justice in the world.
No.
Well the,
well the ones,
the examples that I could pull up,
you know,
especially my favorite example is kind of,
we've been diffused,
you know,
but men see is a bad guy and that's the zoo's a vindictive guy.
Like what he was doing the comics was,
he was going after them.
I take their shit and do it right before they went on stage.
Like that kind of thing.
Take your clothes a bit too.
Right before you go up,
try and kick your legs out from under you.
That was a bad guy and that was the guy who did it for a long time.
He did it for a long time.
It didn't last because eventually people figured it out.
But for a long time it did work.
Sign bad.
I've never had to be around somebody like that.
We're lucky.
Showbiz is shelters them though.
There's a little bit of Shell subtle stuff I've been around,
but like nothing,
nothing.
Uh,
to that hard core level.
I keep thinking that's Ellen degenerate.
Who,
you know,
Hillary Clinton
thought you was talking about now
though,
you're looking at your video.
No,
Ellen's way,
way better.
Way Better looking than Jesus Christ.
Don't do that to her.
I just out of the corner of my eye,
Hillary Clinton,
she's got
Ellen degeneres is old school haircut.
Hillary Clinton who she stole from Wayne Gretzky if you want to really want to
be honest.
Yeah.
That's uh,
yeah.
Wayne Gretzky.
Okay.
I the case she had the head.
This is how that haircut goes before her LNG generous cash as well.
Before that it was Wayne Gretzky,
Patrick sleazy brothers pronouns.
He hasn't main,
mainly about the eighties is a guy had Hillary Clinton's hair.
Like a lot of guys had Hillary Clinton's hair cut in the 80s.
I would have,
if my hair didn't grow out like an Afro,
I would have rocked that thing.
I tried to grow,
grow the mullet.
I did,
but my hair was too wood to Afro.
Wish it would just grow out.
So I look like a redheaded one Epstein.
So I was like,
I can't do this one.
He hits us with a welcome back,
Kotter reference.
Nobody knows who won.
I've seen his man.
He just passed away.
He did just be passed away a few years,
a few months back.
Ah,
he played my brother on Newsradio.
He dead.
How cool was it to meet him?
It was cool.
And it was,
um,
Nick Depaulo,
Brian Cowen and uh,
an Epstein from welcome back.
Kotter.
Did he tell you any,
any,
uh,
one Epstein stories?
They're just happy to be working a nice guy to be around.
Friendly Guy.
It's hard for them.
And it's hard for a lot of those dudes that didn't work.
You know,
they uh,
they did this big hit Sitcom and then they had a hard time getting work after
it.
And meanwhile John Travolta takes off and becomes his fucking gigantic movie
star and just sort of eclipse is them.
And then it becomes a story of well how come these guys haven't gotten any work
with John Travolta is a superstar.
You know,
we're in the same movie TV show is John Travolta.
How come you're not a superstar?
I don't know how actors do it because like if you're on,
if you're on a movie and an end as a convenient,
you still have it.
You just be a comedian,
then you put it on a new hour special and you can like reinvent yourself and all
that.
Like I think trying to make it just as like an actor or character actors,
one of the hardest things ever,
it's gotta be brutal sinner on what,
and that's why so many of them were so phony cause they,
they're constantly being politicians.
They constantly have to sort of protect image.
And sell
a certain image and you know,
they got to try to push things.
Same thing like with actors.
I find that Nice.
So it's definitely a different energy.
It's a much more,
uh,
not as intense.
Lez Comics.
Yeah.
Comics,
you know,
comics,
just the did the,
you're up there by yourself.
People are going to heckle you.
You're,
you have defense.
Defense is up where they're kind of more like a,
they're a little more open,
you know,
they,
they came about this and like acting class and everybody's got to go up there
and as much more healthier sort of easing into this business.
But I mean that's the only way to be as a comic.
Give it.
So it's a nutty fucking business.
No,
absolutely.
Go on stage.
And it was some shit that you wrote down and made up and you're going to tell it
to these people.
They're going to laugh,
are you sure?
And they got to pay money to hear that for an actual isn't the biggest surprise.
The first time you did that,
you wrote something,
you thought it was gonna be funny and then you just say it and there's nothing,
just that fucking invisible kicked in the chest.
You're so confused.
Like I knew this was going to be a huge bit for me.
Like I didn't think I found my new closer or what's worse was when you had one
and it destroyed and then you went out in the first time.
You tried to recreate what you did the night before.
But you were thinking about the night before.
But he didn't realize the reason why it didn't work.
The reason why it worked before it was cause you were in the moment then you
tried to do what you did the night before and it falls flat and that quiet ride
home with yourself.
Yeah.
And this,
there is the reality of different fucking crowds.
You know,
a lot of people like to say it's never the crowd that is absolute horse shit
because there's some crazy fucking crowds and there's some crowds.
We tell a joke,
you know,
it's a great fucking joke.
This is your fucking ace in the hole.
Starting off slow,
but I'm going to hit them with this and away we go.
And clunk,
it just comes out like this.
No,
this is the CRA.
There's something wrong with this fucking crowd.
You know,
when you're just showing up,
did you do any strip clubs or anything like that?
And did you ever,
uh,
MC,
Wasstrip Cloer strip clubs,
rock and roll show.
I'm trying to filter all the ones that I went to and I'm trying to think if
there's ever a show
there ever shown.
Yes.
Did you ever do rotate?
You did.
I did.
There was,
there was this titty bar in New York City,
but this was,
it was weird.
Like on the other side was the titty bar.
It was during that Giuliani stuff where he was like,
okay,
40% of this can't be pornography,
pornography,
pornographic,
pornographic pornography,
pornography.
See,
I'll fucking,
I was trying to say pornographic.
I said pornography and I thought I was on the right track and I just kept going
for pornography,
putting it on,
it's going to come to you.
It's gonna
fuck pornographic.
So uh,
so,
so technically we were there but there was no girls walking around with like
[inaudible] or anything like that.
I just might,
as we remember,
some girl told me a street joke,
a really bad street joke
and involve lifting up,
addressing,
show me her pussy.
What the hell was it?
And I,
and I couldn't get to the heart to tell him that.
I already heard that joke and she went all the way with getting like the Tattoo.
Did you want to see my,
I want to see my pussy.
That's what she wants to eat my pussy.
She lifts up her skirt and it's a tattoo of a cat and says I guess a mouse aided
or what?
I had a flux.
Is it go?
Oh I don't know.
I think that's a tattoo of a cat.
How the fuck does that go?
I don't know.
I can't remember the end of the joke.
And she did it and I had already heard the joke and I want,
I laughed anyways cause I didn't have the heart to be like,
yeah,
I already heard that one.
Someone else says that joke on their body.
Um,
am I bombing at this point?
I feel like I am,
I have to go.
I have to go to this,
this,
this pit pit bull thing.
Yeah.
What does the pit bull thing?
I Dunno.
They're always,
oh,
it's for a shelter,
but it gets people to a rescue.
Those beautiful dogs that are fucking awesome and they have your back and
they'll love you to death in the face off to come to the door.
Tough action around other dogs.
You have to be careful.
You know what it's like.
It's like,
it's like driving a sports car.
You have a lethal weapon that there's,
there's,
there's a responsibility.
It's like owning a gun.
It's like anything else.
It's not like either one of those things because you can control both of those
things.
You can't control an animal.
You need to step into my Dojo dogs.
Uh,
I love pit bulls to death,
but they're dangerous dogs.
They are dangerous dogs.
But you respect that,
but you have to respect that they are dangerous.
That's why I worked with a trainer for like almost a year and at this point me
and my girl could take a dog,
walk it through a bunch of five year olds holding raw meat and there wouldn't be
a fucking problem.
It just wouldn't be.
You say that,
but you don't know that because dawn's do strange things.
I had a dog killed one of my dogs.
Yeah,
I know.
Came home and saw a fucking bloodbath in the kitchen.
I never would have signed up.
Did that.
I know,
but also,
but how much did you read up on the breed before you got it?
Oh,
I read up a lot.
I've had them for years.
I've had them for most of my life.
I don't want to get into this.
Look,
I love the dogs.
I like dogs.
I sat here,
I supported you and your lifestyle.
And as I'm walking out hyping my fucking little charity thing,
I'm going to,
all of a sudden I'm getting static.
I see.
I see how this game is.
You know what this is,
do love them.
This is a bait and switch.
I do love them.
And I am.
I
look at it,
don't,
all dogs are fucking nuts.
I'm nuts.
These are great dogs.
I don't find it that it's tougher than I'll ever be.
It's like,
well you know,
you ever see my body guard?
That's what my dog is.
I'm like the little nerd riding on the handlebars.
Trying to find that piece for the carburetor.
You have a pit bull?
Yes I do.
How was he around other dogs?
Uh,
like slow dogs gets competitive with big dogs so we don't take it to the dog
park.
Problem solved.
Just to make sure that you have like a sturdy leash and he never had him around
dogs.
Right?
Yeah,
I have way beyond them.
That's like me saying,
listen,
make sure you don't stick your thumbs in here when you make a fist.
That's what you're saying to me right now.
Okay.
No I'm not,
I'm not even suggesting it.
I'm just asking you how you do it.
Like what is your,
do you have a philosophy behind it?
Cause some people don't have that philosophy.
They just say,
I see problems come in and I just across um,
across the street,
I just,
you know,
they,
everybody has an opinion of martial arts version of just avoiding the fight.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There's that hoping that their collar,
yeah.
You got to have the right kind of college.
You have to know what to do with the call.
If you know what to do and how to hold the leash,
you can get that thing going to go the same way you get something in a hold and
where they want to stand up and sit down,
they have no fucking control.
Right.
Because they're like,
ah.
It's the same thing with like,
you know,
the next line,
that point.
Bye.
Okay.
Yeah.
Choker collar.
The ones with,
no,
no.
Those are fine.
Yeah.
I don't do that.
Listen,
you're going to get me in trouble here.
I have to go to a fucking tree huggers right now.
All right man.
We'll save some pit bulls and time.
You want to come back and do it again when,
when can people see you do stand up?
When I used to be at the Improv in San Jose this weekend,
this weekend,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
my whole new hours coming together.
And,
uh,
and,
and that is it.
The San Jose Improv is fucking awesome.
That's what I love the old theater.
That's a cool old historic place,
you know?
So,
uh,
thanks.
Come,
uh,
follow bill burr on Twitter.
We the one where the ones that talk to me to get a Twitter page and now you got
like 100,000 people on that Shit,
right?
I was the first one to make you on Brian up there.
Yeah.
Was responsible for you.
Thank you for your digital revolution.
It's bill burr B.
I.
L.
B.
You are.
Thanks buddy.
Awesome.
All right,
we'll see.
Thanks sue.
Uh,
should we just end this?
Brian,
you have anything more to say?
No.
Okay.
Friday night,
uh,
ice house,
10:30 PM show.
We got so far a Mab lineup of Brendan Walsh.
Um,
who else is it?
Brendan Wallace,
Christian,
maybe.
Maybe Burberry for crusher.
Eliza,
Doug Benson.
I go to Naca and a couple of other people if that Shit's devastating people 10
10 30 show and me.
Oh yeah,
I'm on that show too.
Thank you sir.
Oh,
nick use too.
Kicking in the throat kicks in the night.
I should question called that should I named my special that throwing kicks in
at night.
Um,
that's it.
So come on down.
Friday night ice house in Pasadena to go to ice house comedy.com for more
details.
Thank you to the flashlight for sponsoring our podcasts.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight and if you enter in a code name rogue and
you will save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Go get them.
Boys were also sponsored by on at.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and the source of more twats on my message board than any
other product I've ever been involved with in my life.
I want to thank you for exposing yourself.
Haters are like fucking snake venom.
You gotta go later.
Gilbert,
I'm going to to go to [inaudible] dot com click on the link for what does it
say?
Alpha brain on my website.
I didn't remember the link says,
cause I'll use a code name Brogan.
Save yourself 10% off any and all orders.
Lots of new stuff is coming down the pipes,
including these kettlebells and uh,
the protein powder,
the kettle bells.
I think you can buy them now online,
but I'll let you know when the official launch happens.
All right,
you dirty bitches.
We will see you Friday with an icehouse chronicles that you could only listen to
online on Ustream.
I'm I my Ustream page or on iTunes on death squad.
So subscribe and we'll see you soon.
Bye Bye.
Oh.